notre correspondant gulliver craag s'est
rendu quant à lui dans la banlieue de la
capitale kiev
je me trouve actuellement à ce qui était
l'une des principales positions de
l'artillerie russe pendant les batailles
dire pin et de boudhha les villes
satellites juste en dehors de quêtes
vous pouvez voir les boîtes de munitions
les caisses encore ici ça et là et les
positions où l'artillerie s'est trouvée
c'était l'une des positions importantes
mais c'était loin d'être la seule il y
avait beaucoup de positions comme ça
comme l'attestent la destruction massive
de ces villes particulièrement de ir pin
et on peut supposer qu'il y a des
positions maintenant similaires non loin
des principales villes du donbass comme
severodonetsk ou encore comme archives
dans le nord est de l'ukraine des
endroits qui sont actuellement sous le
feu des russes qui les poursuivent leurs
attaques sur l'est de l'ukraine surtout
sous forme de barrages d'artillerie nous
avons demandé aux soldats et craignent
un qui nous ont accompagnés ici et qui
n'étaient pas à soda avant le 24 février
qui se sont mobilisés juste après
l'invasion russe pour faire face à cette
offensive si il avait peur d'aller dans
les styles ont dit qu il se préparait
pour y aller mais que bien sûr qu'ils
avaient peur il faudrait être fou pour
ne pas avoir un peu peur mais cependant
il s'est dit confiant que les russes
n'allait pas être capable de prendre les
régions de donetsk est lougansk est que
la défense ukrainienne allait se montrer
suffisamment solides comme elle l'a fait
pour la défense des airs pin et de
boudhha mais bien sûr un coût humain
très élevé